all right i i think we're rolling we are
allegedly live
uh
welcome everyone thanks for joining us
this is our first ever
stronger by science live podcast
thanks for joining us uh this is the
next step in the evolution of the
podcast
where's that audio coming from
um
i think it's coming from that computer
we are having very expected technical
difficulties
i'm the one that missed it i got it
okay okay did that fix it
i think it did i don't know where else
it would be coming from
cool uh all right so people can hear us
that's good one of the questions there
is why we're so handsome i like that
we're off to a great start
but yeah so when we first started the
podcast we mentioned that the stated
goal was basically to become the next
bill o'reilly rush limbaugh combination
and obviously they do stuff
live in front of the camera not just
audio so quite famously so so here we
are in front of the silver sbs
microphones and we're ready to go so
before we get into a bunch of
questions um first of all make sure you
sign up for the newsletter make sure you
join the facebook group and the
subreddit um
we'll find a way to put links uh into
this at some point but
people who are here for this they're
probably already parts of those
communities
one one would hope i think so um and
yeah if you need supplements go over to
bulksupplements.com use the promo code
sbs pod you get five percent off your
order
uh
all right we should be good to go let's
do it did you have oh i should
acknowledge a little tactical error on
our part
um
we explicitly
uh
scheduled this
to cater to our american audience based
on the time zones yeah and scheduled it
right over top of a bunch of really good
college football games so
i don't know
what we were thinking there but
thank you for choosing us over college
football
and you can always check the scores when
we're done
all right greg did you have any specific
question
that you were stoked about answering
first
um i mean i i was planning on
basically just answering questions as
they came in we've got a live audience
here give them what they want cool uh
and then if things slow down we can
scroll back up to the top and and see
what's lurking for us up there does that
work for you
sure yeah you want to start at the very
top or like the newest one uh i mean
like
fairly new uh first off shout out to
janic 2 a.m german dude checking in
good work i would not be listening to
this at 2am but more power to you also
luca
um
here's a meaty one to lead off on uh
poncer study please help us interpret
the total energy expenditure difference
do you want to talk about ponzor stuff
yeah so this is uh an exciting time for
all the ponzer heads out there um and
i'm sure there are many uh so
poncer they
he and a very big group of collaborators
put out a couple studies the last couple
weeks and that's pretty common you'll
work on a big big big project and then
papers will kind of all
hit the journals in a really relatively
short time frame
and so they had the one paper that was
looking at uh total daily energy
expenditure over the life span so
they they had this enormous data set
with like 6 000 people or something like
that
ranging from
literally newborns to people in their
mid 90s there were
pregnant women in the study at all
stages of pregnancy so it was a really
cool look at really good
valid data on total daily energy
expenditure measured via doubly labeled
water which is uh the gold standard when
it comes to uh measuring it in free free
living people who are going about their
business which is good because we if we
want to know people's daily energy
expenditure we want them to be doing
their normal day-to-day stuff
so uh there was that study
but there was also another study where
they looked at um
the way that total daily energy
expenditure can be kind of constrained
when
activity is intentionally sought out so
as activity level goes up um you know
one of poncer's one of the ideas that
he's really known for is the idea that
we kind of offset that by reducing basal
metabolic rate to to an extent and
reducing potentially non-exercise
activity as well so those were the two
studies and i'm not certain necessarily
which one the question is referring to
but i think uh these two studies were
extremely well done they're really
impressive collaborative efforts a
tremendous amount of time and resources
went into both and i think both of the
studies showed some fairly intuitive
findings so the first one
basically indicated that
the major determinant of an individual's
total daily energy expenditure is their
fat free mass
and within most of the adult uh you know
from the age of like 20 to 60 or
something like that
total daily energy expenditure was
relatively stable
and the the most reliable predictor of
it was fat-free mass it didn't really
differ much based on biological sex
surprisingly did it differ that much
during pregnancy into the post-pregnancy
period that one honestly surprised me
the most i was surprised by that finding
in particular but
uh
basically from 20 to 60 a lot of people
as we mentioned on a recent episode they
kind of say oh once you turn 40 once you
turn 50 you know it all goes downhill
you start gaining fat mass i think that
the two interesting findings from the
poncer study was that was pretty stable
up to the age of about 60 and then there
was a decline but uh
after 60 what was interesting was there
was a decline in total daily energy
expenditure but there was not an
increase in fat mass basically
sarcopenia just kind of set in activity
level went down and potentially organ
level energy expenditure went down as
well so there were reductions at the
ages of 60 and above um but but it looks
like those are largely due in part to
reductions in activity level but also in
part due to reductions in fat free mass
and even specifically maybe
even at the tissue level there was some
reduction in the energy expenditure of
those specific fat-free tissues
but they kind of left that open-ended
because they weren't certain exactly
what was going on there
the other poncho paper recently looked
at uh we haven't really covered this in
any of our content but i have briefly
looked at it and it was the same general
approach uh in terms of the study but
basically it it largely confirmed his
general uh hypothesis that
when humans increase their
their active energy expenditure there is
some degree of compensation where they
reduce
either resting energy expenditure or
non-exercise activity expenditure
with the method they used it was kind of
hard to discern exactly what was being
constrained
neat versus resting metabolic rate uh
but what they did find in the study was
there was compensation but it wasn't
complete compensation it's not like if
you increased your activity by 150
calories your resting energy expenditure
drops by 150 and you're in the same
place it was an incomplete compensation
where a fraction of the activity energy
expenditure was offset by some
uh
constraint uh placed on other types of
energy expenditure one of the really
fascinating things was that it wasn't
the same for everybody
people with higher body fat tended to
have a greater compensation which meant
for people who had higher body fat if
they did some exercise to burn off
calories they were more likely to find a
way to conserve calories elsewhere
resting energy expenditure or
non-exercise activity and so the
question that they left kind of
open-ended there was a bit of a chicken
and egg scenario you know is it that um
these individuals developed high body
fat because their compensators or is it
that as you develop more body fat you
start to compensate more if i had to
guess i would think the former rather
than the latter well yeah there's um
[Music]
ah man what was his name again bouchard
back in the day uh did some twin studies
on that which you know uh
theoretically if you're seeing
similar changes within twin pairs that
suggest that there's probably a genetic
component to it i
did an overfeeding study like back in
the back in the 80s or early 90s um
basically finding that the
uh
the amount of weight gained
per
the amount of weight gained relative to
predicted weight gain uh varied
considerably between twin pairs from you
know i i think the total over feeding
was like 84 000 calories uh and some of
the twin pairs gained like
90 as much weight as one would expect uh
assuming you just taken 84 000
additional calories with no compensation
in energy expenditure uh
and then i think the the most like
blessed twin pairs um
only gained like 20
of what would be expected uh again with
like relatively strong correlations
within twin pairs um
so obviously that's overfeeding and and
compensations to that rather than
exercise
but i i
i mean i think it is probably both
chicken and egg but i think it's more
chicken
yeah
all right um
let's see something popped up somebody
asked about
rhodiola didn't you just
put out a little bit of content on
rhodiola yeah do you want to briefly
give an overview of that since it came
up in the chat here uh yeah where where
was the question
um let's see did it just come out matt
yeah matt asked the question to either
of you think there's enough evidence to
recommend rhodiola and or l-dopa in a
pre-workout or is the evidence not very
okay okay cool so it's asking
specifically about a pre-workout yeah um
so
yeah within that context it might depend
what kind of training goal you have um
so there have been two
uh
two
anaerobic exercise studies with rhodiola
to this point so
one of them used repeated sprints so
three
half wingate tests so 15 second all-out
anaerobic sprint tests uh and then the
most recent one
used a multi-set rep to failure protocol
i believe on bench press that one just
came out last month or like two months
ago pretty recently
and the interesting thing that both of
them found
was that rhodiola consumed uh
pre-workout i think in the uh i think it
was just consumed pre-workout in the
cycling study and was consumed for like
two weeks beforehand in addition to
pre-workout in the bench press study but
regardless the the final dose was taken
during the pre-workout window uh and in
both of them when people used rhodiola
it improved power output so like peak
power output during a wind gate test uh
and like bar velocity and power output
uh
during i think a single set of three
reps on bench press at 70 1rm
so it improved uh like peak power output
based metrics
but in the cycling study the subjects
taking
rhodiola had a slightly greater fatigue
index so basically from the start of the
first sprint to the end of the last
sprint they experienced a slightly
larger decrease in power output
and also in the most recent bench press
study the subjects taking rhodiola in
spite of having uh greater power output
when they were fresh
actually completed slightly fewer reps
over either like three or four sets to
failure um so it seems like rhodiola
when taken pre-workout might improve
kind of like top-end peak power output
and maybe force output as well
but might actually decrease strength
endurance and increase fatigability to
some degree so
obviously we're talking about two
studies here so this is very very
preliminary but based on the preliminary
evidence it looks like rhodiola as a
pre-workout
if you're doing like a really heavy
fairly low volume strength workout or a
fairly low volume power based workout
might be beneficial for acute
performance uh whereas if you're doing
like a really high volume like
bodybuilding workout it might actually
be slightly ergolytic um
so again we're talking about two studies
here but based on two studies that is
the current state of the evidence
that is two more studies that we have uh
in comparison to tercesterone and we did
get a
a trolling kind of question about
torches so that is true i might as well
address that um because i did notice so
in a recent episode we talked about how
there's just oh actually before we get
into this uh there was a follow-up
question
um
asking about like standardizing based on
salidroside versus rosevin for the for
the rhodiola uh both of the studies to
this point have used the now foods
formulation
which i think
is
standardized to three percent
salidrocides and one percent rooseven um
so whether some other ratio is better or
not i don't know but that's that's
what's been tested so far
yeah that's a tricky thing with
supplement research is like when you
only have a handful of studies on a
particular ingredient for a particular
outcome and it can be standardized
different ways or it can be dosed
different ways it takes a long time to
figure out what the optimal dose is i
mean especially when you're dealing with
herbal extracts yeah there's like
hundreds of potentially bioactive
ingredients yeah
um
but anyway yeah one thing i did want to
mention uh after we talked about how
there's really just no
human terrestrial evidence
and certainly no human tercastrone
evidence that we know of
uh looking at performance or hypertrophy
or anything like that uh you know we
mentioned that on the podcast and some
people kind of interpreted the ambiguity
as
uh optimism you know it was kind of like
we said ah there's no evidence for it no
evidence against it
um
and i think some people interpreted that
as a completely 50 50 coin toss
um so it is worth mentioning that like
i'm a bit of a skeptic
uh so like
there is no evidence to to indicate that
it does or does not affect performance
or hypertrophy but my skepticism is
based on
uh
a series of other phyto fd steroids that
to this point have failed to pan out
in the relevant literature available so
since we got a question about
tercastrone i figured i would address
that briefly
uh
someone just pointed out i'm not
particularly bronze um
i was only bronzed for one day in like
2017 but the whole internet thinks i
look like that every day yeah i'll i'll
be honest uh
i was i was surprised at what you looked
like the first time i saw you because
the only picture of you i'd ever seen
was your author photo at jts
uh where you were
very shredded and very orange
yeah
yeah no i'm neither but that's okay hey
omar stopped by he did he's asked uh two
trolling questions so far uh previously
he asked what your opinions were about
marijuana
uh
and he also asked could we define pain
as a callback to uh
a round table that
were you on that or i was well
yeah you were like moderating it i was
moderating and my my internet dropped
out like three times so i basically
caught the opening and i said bye to
everybody and that was about it yeah it
was it was a it was a round table on
whether uh exercise technique influences
injury risk uh and so
we started by being like okay so let's
just
try to start with a a operational
definition of injury that we can all
agree to
and it just went around and around for
like 45 minutes or an hour and we never
settled on a definition that everyone
could agree with uh at one point it went
towards what if it's just an increase in
entropy in the system
yeah
so and eventually we're like okay we
need to keep this rolling yeah i think
one of the reasons it's particularly
funny to me is because omar
really explicitly told me that my job as
a moderator was just to usher us through
the definition process to keep it snappy
and the moment we started that my my
internet dropped and my internet came
back like six hours later and we were
just wrapping that up and i was like i
had one job and i did not accomplish
that but it was it was a fun round table
i thought it was good
people got useful stuff out of it there
are varying opinions
all right do you have any uh training
related questions that are popping up uh
yeah yeah someone
uh
several comments back
asked
if you're bench pressing
and your goal is not just primarily
power lifting you know if you're not
just trying to increase one rm at all
cost uh
does it make sense to still arch or you
know should you just bench flat back
and honestly i think that a lot of that
just has has to do with proportions um
i think that if you're mostly benching
for
hypertrophy
uh most people with most builds it
probably makes the most sense uh to
either not arch at all or not have much
of an arch just so you're you're working
through a slightly longer range of
motion especially at uh like end range
of motion for the muscles you're trying
to train
uh but with that said
uh i i used to train a fair number of
basketball players and
they were uh most of them just
very lanky [ __ ] uh and for them
uh the ones that could arch
binge press was so much more comfortable
if they arched just because like
their proportions were so absurd
that
uh
just looking at the way their shoulders
were moving i really wouldn't recommend
them bench to their chest uh just just
because their arms were so long
um so yeah the the ones who could arch
i'd have a march everyone else i would
just let them do two board press um so
yeah there are situations where i'd
still recommend arching if you're not
primarily training for powerlifting but
uh for the most part i i don't think
it's necessary
yeah so
for me personally greg you know i bench
with a really minimal arch like i pretty
much bench flat back yeah uh and for me
it's to basically uh
for some reason it just feels better for
me with uh i've got a bit of a
injury history with my shoulder and for
whatever reason when i get a really
severe arch um i've got like a broken
collarbone separated ac joint that i
didn't let heal like for me personally i
can just get way more out of a block of
training benching if i go flat back and
accommodate how that feels versus a
really extreme arch so
like you said it's not really a cut and
dry thing it you have to kind of feel
feel out what's working for you and
what's going to give you
not just the quickest strength gains but
you know
make sure that you're achieving the goal
you have you know so for me personally
training purely for pec growth and
trying to make sure i get as much as i
can out of that training block
i'm not going to take on extra you know
grinding and pain in the shoulder just
to put a few more apart pounds on the
bar
using a form that it's probably going to
even take a little bit of that focus
away from the pec anyway yeah you know i
mean i i've got another very spicy uh
very spicy take on bench press
honestly if someone's not training for
powerlifting i don't know that i'd
recommend they bench in the first place
oh
it's not that's bad for the brand it's
it's not a bad exercise by any means
yeah um
but i think that
i don't know what you gained from
bingeing that you can't get from
dumbbell press and i so i
you know if there was like a pro con
matrix i wouldn't really put anything as
a pro for bench press that wouldn't also
be on the dumbbell press one but i think
there are additional pros of dumbbell
press uh and the cons mostly relate to
maximal loading like you know you can do
triples on bench press way easier than
you can do triples on dumbbell press uh
but if you're not a power lifter like
who cares um so yeah i think you can
target your pecs a little bit better
with dumbbells and also like most people
just i've observed find that the most
comfortable
uh groove to press in is not with like
fully pronated wrists um like for their
elbows shoulders wrists whatever else um
you know not like a fully neutral grip
but somewhere between pronated and
neutral tends to be the most comfortable
and like there are specialty bars that
can accommodate that but also dumbbells
accommodate that um
and then really the only major advantage
i could see with barbells is they do
probably hit your triceps a little bit
harder but also like bench press isn't
that great of a triceps exercise in the
first place so like you're gonna be
doing extra triceps work anyway
hopefully um
so yeah i mean i i would mostly just
recommend
uh not binching if you're not a power
lifter um
i will say it's very valid to bench
press just because you know people are
gonna ask you like
how much do you bench uh but otherwise
like i i don't think it's better for
most goals than dumbbell press
yeah
all right moving on
uh we did have somebody ask a question
about outfits i think somebody tried to
catch me not wearing george but they're
way off
i have
uh george
athletic pant on and i've got george
boxer reefs on actually so i'm very
georged out this shirt was one of the
ones from michaels that i did mention on
the podcast you cannot find a better
shirt for three dollars than this one
and someone asked why i was wearing such
flashy colors and it's to uh support the
buckeyes tonight for the big game very
nice
all right um
i did see an interesting question in
here but i lost track of it
yeah so frank s
asked if surplus calories eventually can
become maintenance calories if all other
factors are kept the same uh and the
answer is yes the answer is uh you know
that that uh
happens quite often when we're trying to
bulk you know so
uh if you start a bulking phase trying
to gain some weight gain some muscle
you know you'll start out with a
particular caloric target for the day
you know
hit that target day in and day out
you'll start gaining some weight
and eventually you'll find that some
combination of two things happens so
first of all uh you're going to be
adding weight if you if you are in this
caloric surplus and hopefully a large
percentage of that is muscle and so as
we start you know
as we have more tissue accretion
especially if it's fat-free tissue we're
gonna see that our energy expenditure uh
increases not just from increasing
resting energy expenditure but also you
know if you're
carrying a heavier body around all day
that does have some effect on total
daily energy expenditure as well
so part of the reason we're going to see
our energy needs go up is because we
have more active tissue
but another part is that
most people have some degree of upward
adaptation to a caloric surplus
what's really fascinating is that the
magnitude of that
adaptation is highly variable so
there's a study i'm thinking of where
they brought people in for i think six
weeks six to eight weeks something like
that they overfed them by a thousand
calories a day uh and we're just like
hey let's watch people gain some weight
and i think the researchers
were a little bit surprised at the
degree of variability that was observed
uh where you know some people when they
were overfed a thousand calories a day
uh
they had this big up regulation in total
daily energy expenditure that really
attenuated weight gain i mean not
entirely but to a really impressive
degree it was a real physiologically it
was an impre an impressive magnitude of
adaptation to see uh it was more than i
would have otherwise thought people were
capable of to be honest and then uh a
lot of people in the sample who had a
higher propensity to weight gain there
was just really minimal adaptation you
gave them a thousand calories a day
extra and they stored
most at that thousand calories a day we
might be thinking of the same study
the one i think of i believe is by
levine and colleagues oh okay uh but uh
but basically uh so yeah when you are
bulking and you you set your
first set of calories that's going to
get you somewhere but that's probably
you know if you want to continue gaining
weight for a really long time and you
have really ambitious
bulking goals you're probably going to
have to increase your calories again at
some point
because your surplus has now become your
maintenance
some of that is an upregulation of
energy expenditure and some of that is
just having a bigger body
just to expand on that a little bit the
the compensation and we've talked about
this before on the podcast uh it goes in
both directions like people
have some degree of compensation to
increase energy intake um some people
have
most people have some degree of
compensation and most people have some
degree of compensation to decreases in
energy intake and so functionally like
there a lot of people just kind of have
like a dead zone in terms of calories
and i think one of one of the things
that uh often frustrates people who
don't have much experience with either
losing or gaining weight um
is you know like maybe you hear that
rule of thumb like oh if you uh if you
cut your calories by 500 per day you'll
lose about a pound a week
not exactly true but generally it gets
you in the right ballpark at least in in
terms of if the math works out but since
there is kind of that dead zone uh if
you were maybe like
like let's say there's a 500 calorie
range that that for you is functionally
maintenance if you were somewhere near
the top of that range maybe like 200
calories above the midpoint then
dropping 500 calories like uh maybe now
you're in a deficit but it's a very very
small deficit and you're not losing
weight at nearly the rate you thought
you would uh
and i think for people who
um classically classify themselves as
hard gainers i think it goes the
opposite direction they they have
a lot of room for adaptation to
increases in energy intake and so you
know they're maybe near the bottom of
that dead zone and so like they increase
their calories by 200 per day because
they're they're trying to lean bulk not
gain weight super fast they may still
functionally be at maintenance there
because they almost completely
compensate for it um so i think that's
something to keep in mind when you're
trying to either lose or gain weight um
you know the initial diet setup is just
part of the story like you definitely
need to keep adapting um and monitoring
as you go and oftentimes if you're
trying to lose weight you're gonna have
to drop your calories
a decent bit more than you thought you
would have if you did know your
maintenance and same thing like
oftentimes if you're trying to gain
weight you're gonna have to increase
your calories a little bit more than you
thought you would uh if you already know
your maintenance just because you do
kind of have that dead zone in the
middle yeah
um
oh uh
william patrick had a question he asked
uh oh into that i respond i owe
i i also respond io that's excellent to
hear uh so i i need to respond to a
question from nog heads uh because he's
i think put this in the chat about five
times already uh he asked i recently
heard jeff nippard say he no longer
believes volume is the primary driver of
volume i assume that's hypertrophy
is this no longer the prevailing belief
so
is
is training volume the primary driver of
hypertrophy or not and honestly
as time goes on as i get older and wiser
i kind of don't even like that
classification anymore like trying to
determine like what is
uh the primary driver of something
uh
either you know hypertrophy strength
whatever because one yeah you have to
talk about like what time scale are you
talking about uh and two
i i view it more now in the frame of
necessary versus sufficient conditions
so
you know it's all well and good to say
oh training volume is the primary driver
of hypertrophy but then oftentimes the
counter is someone will be like oh no
like it's all about intensity like in
the classic bodybuilding definition like
not percentage of 1rm but like getting
close enough to failure like that's what
it's all about
and
i think they're both right uh because
when taken to an extreme if you say like
oh like volume is the primary driver and
i'm going to assume that's the major
variable so maybe i can let some other
things slide
in the interest of maximizing training
volume well then it makes sense like hey
i'm not going to go close to failure at
all because if i'm trying to maximize
the tonnage or the number of sets that
i'm doing per workout
i just can't do as much if i'm going
close to failure every set so if i'm
trying to maximize volume
on a set by basis like i'm going to
train like a wimp so i can get more
total volume in and then you know
oftentimes you'll have substandard
results uh but then you know on the flip
side
i i do find most um
like most natural lifters do need more
volume than say
the the very old school
high intensity training approach where
you just do
one set five reps pass failure and then
rest for two weeks uh so you know if
someone says it's all about intensity
you maximize intensity you'll you'll
maximize results uh you know if you're
if you're going that route and saying
like okay this is the proxy that i'm the
the thing i can measure that i'm going
to attempt to optimize for and let other
things go by the wayside like maybe
training volume then you'll also have
substandard results so i
i mean it's it's hard to say what the
primary driver is because there are so
many factors that
are important to still include like you
need to be doing enough volume you need
to have solid exercise selection you
need to be going close enough to failure
like you you need to be eating enough
calories you need to be eating enough
protein you need to be sleeping enough
like you could make the argument like oh
no actually the main driver of
hypertrophy is protein intake because if
you didn't eat any protein you wouldn't
gain any muscle in fact you would die
but like you know obviously eating
enough protein isn't sufficient to
maximize hypertrophy so
ultimately i don't even care what the
main driver is uh and i don't even know
how i would be able to define
functionally what it means to be the
primary driver of hypertrophy uh
i think there are a lot of things that
contribute and you just can't neglect
any of them
yeah
that actually
kind of it doesn't
totally relate but you could kind of
build off from that
and address a question that came up
earlier it's kind of buried in the
comments at this point but someone
mentioned that they're a busy grad
student and they're wondering you know
basically
how can they get by you know
what's the the least they have to do
basically to try to achieve hypertrophy
or maintain lean mass i can't remember
exactly what the stated goal was
but um
you know one of the things i worry about
with that kind of blanket statement that
volume is the key driver is that i think
a lot of people
hear that and they say well i can't
train 12 hours a week so i guess i'm
screwed you know because at the end of
the day volume
volume in my mind means time like it's
it's kind of tough to do a really high
volume program on a really crunch time
budget it can be really challenging to
do that
uh
but uh
you know i would say as a a response to
that question and a note of
encouragement i guess for people who are
uh concerned that they can't invest the
amount of time required to have a
traditional high volume training program
i very much was that busy grad student
for
quite a few years
and like
my basic guidance would be if you can
try to hit each muscle group twice per
week
you're probably going to be in pretty
good shape you know and with
you know appropriate proximity to
failure you know leaving
one or two or three reps in the tank for
most sets get into the gym make sure
you're hitting each body part each main
muscle group twice a week and that can
be two full body workouts it can be
upper lower upper lower you'll know what
you have time for
and if your grad school is anything like
like mine it could be different every
week you know so there would be some
weeks where
i'd be like all right i'm just gonna go
to the gym
uh twice and do do a couple full body
workouts and just see what i can get
done in an hour you know and then there
would be other weeks where i could kind
of split things out a little bit so i
think that's one of the downsides of
everybody pushing you know you got to
have this particular set and rep or this
particular rep range and volume's the
key driver and then people are like well
then all my workouts are supposed to be
like two hours you know that's really
not necessary for most goals and also if
the question is
you know what is sufficient for
maintenance uh
i think people are often shocked
especially if you're reasonably young
and healthy and not in a huge caloric
deficit
how little training you can get you can
get away with and still be able to
maintain most of your muscle most of
your strength if not all of it
so uh for example i was just a co-author
on a paper from uh
pack one of our coaches at stronger by
science um
i was gonna attempt to pronounce yeah no
i i think i remember his name patroclus
andrew lochus coracus i'm sure if we
have any greek people listening i'm sure
they're very angry right now uh but
anyway pack great guy uh he he did his
um phd research on what is the minimum
effective training dose not just to
maintain strength but to increase
strength uh and he found that um
like just one or two workouts per
exercise working up to
a heavy single uh and then with a couple
drop back sets was enough for most
people who were already reasonably
strong to still make some strength gains
so if all you're trying to do is
maintenance you can get away with even
less than that
and then on the hypertrophy side of
things
there was an older study i want to say
it was maybe like 2003 2004
um
but it it's a classic in kind of like
the the volume reduction in in uh muscle
maintenance area of research basically
they they trained uh some younger folks
and some older folks uh for for 12 weeks
16 weeks something like that and they
wanted to see how much they could then
reduce volume by and people still be
able to maintain what they had gained
for for a reasonably long period of time
i think they were looking over a span of
16 weeks 24 weeks something like that uh
and they found that in the younger
subjects they were able to reduce
training volume to one-ninth of what it
had been previously and they were able
to maintain the muscle that they built
uh in the older subjects with reducing
to one-ninth
they did lose some muscle there but
older folks could still reduce it to
one-third of what they'd been doing
previously
and still be able to maintain what they
previously built so yeah if maintenance
is the goal you can get away with
astoundingly little training uh and be
able to hold on to what you got um and
you know you'll you'll need considerably
more to keep gaining strength keep and
especially keep gaining muscle but just
to hold on to what you currently have
you can probably reduce training volume
from a
effective dose to gain strength or
muscle at a decent clip you can probably
drop it 75 and be just fine for for
maintenance
over the the pretty long term
good stuff
yeah i tried to go back and find that
question i think i might have made it up
i
i think it just kind of came out of my
subconscious all that all those
repressed thoughts of being too busy
because of grad school i just i made up
the question
okay no somebody saw the question
ryan saw the question he attest that it
was real
ryan has asked a few times about some
dating advice and that is technically
allowed since we did cover that in one
of our fireside chats yeah sure sure why
not and the question was basically like
within the three days of a date what can
you do
to kind of make your physique
more impressive uh to kind of
basically how do i peak my physique for
a date yeah um
i can't stress this enough this is
critically important this is
because i dude i have been there i have
been there
when
yeah
just forget about your physique and the
date will go a thousand times better i
absolutely guarantee it uh
if you're on a date and you're thinking
the whole time like i wonder how my feet
physique is looking i wonder how this is
working
it's not gonna go well try to connect
with your date have a good time showcase
your personality
that's the best bet by far
uh
if you if you really want to try to
stack the deck in your favor
before you go to the date i don't know
get a quick pump or something but just
don't show up really sweaty uh and you
know maybe have some extra carbs the day
before if you've been dieting you know
might get you a little bit more glycogen
replenishment but
my advice more than anything is just do
not think about your physique at all
when you're on the date
ask interesting questions uh
be interesting you know
anything to add to that
i mean my most of my dating advice would
relate to
picking up high school girls in 2008 so
uh when you were in high school correct
which is important to stress so
yeah
i don't know what the dating market in
in 2021 is like so
i i'm probably not of much use there
yeah i have been in a relationship for a
long time now so
things move so fast in the world i i
probably have no basis for giving dating
advice either
three three years is like an eternity
i'll take your word for it
um
all right uh so what else do we have
here
uh
it's mostly just people [ __ ] posting
about
dating and physiques now
yeah
there were two questions that came up
that relate to some stuff i did in grad
school and i figured i might as well
address those briefly so
one person asked uh
what is a normal creatine kinase level
for someone who's lifting
uh that comes up a lot and it
i we've mentioned this on the podcast
before but it's really common for people
to reach out to a fitness professional
and say i just went to the doctor they
did routine blood work my doctor says
i'm dying because my creatine kinase is
too high and there's usually some other
things you know maybe creatinine might
be high maybe some liver enzymes might
be elevated a little bit and it can be
really jarring and if your physician
isn't particularly
uh
like knowledgeable about exercise
specifically they might freak out when
they when they see that kind of blood
panel but you know a lot of times that's
just reflecting muscle damage um
of course there are serious medical
conditions that do manifest as really
high creatine kinase readings so you
shouldn't just flatly ignore this type
of stuff but you want to contextualize
it so if you have been doing a really
hard block of training had an unusually
hard workout
uh you know did some type of exercise
you're not accustomed to
um
you know that's the type of thing where
your creatine kindness is going to be
elevated well above the normal level uh
it's not an unusual uh
it's not unusual for that to occur there
is a study uh where we when i was in
grad school we're trying to induce
muscle damage to
then study recovery you know which is
very common when you look at studies on
recovery modalities they'll be like hey
why don't you run downhill for an hour
and like that's that's brutal uh or
let's do like you know a million sets to
failure and see how you do over the next
72 hours and like the answer is not well
or uh when i was doing my lit review for
for my thesis um i was looking at
recovery in males and females and one of
the studies i came across
uh was looking at force recovery of the
biceps uh after a fatigue protocol
consisting of
15 five sets of 15
maximal eccentric
bicep curl reps
um
and one of the things they specifically
pulled out in that study
is uh they they were looking at the
rates of
i forget what terminology terminology
they use but basically people who uh
fatigued or who recovered exceptionally
slowly i think they operationally define
that as people who
still had a 25 reduction in force output
a week after the exercise bout so you
know
like let's say you can curl a hundred
pounds or something as a 1rm like a week
later you still can't do 75 for one uh
so that's like the level of uh
of fatigue you're talking about
in muscle damage you're talking about in
in some of those damage protocols used
in the research uh in that study from
pre to post the maximum isometric
voluntary contraction force for the
biceps on average uh decreased by like
76 in the subjects
which is outrageous like the typical
healthy young male
is like about four times stronger than
the typical like sarcopenic female so
we're talking about taking strapping
young bucks and turning them into old
ladies in the nursing home at least in
terms of bicep strength yeah so so some
of those uh some of those muscle damage
protocols are absolutely insane
yeah yeah so uh
in that
line of research and in the research we
did during grad school like
creatine kinase levels often get out of
the normal range even with day-to-day
training uh creatine kinase levels tend
to be
just with athletes like normative data
for athletes is different when you
compare it to normative data for
non-athletes because athletes are
typically training whenever you bring
them in to test them so
it's not super uncommon it's not
something that would be
particularly jarring if you see that on
your blood work but you do want to
investigate that maybe
next time you do a deload go in and
check verify make sure everything's
looking normal maybe you take a few days
off and repeat the blood test you know
just to get that peace of mind make sure
there's nothing uh that needs to be
addressed there
uh so i don't know the exact number uh
where i would start to panic like in
creatine kinase the units are kind of
wacky like
you see studies where the numbers are
just enormous and then they drop down
precipitously i i'm not good enough with
units to have a number off the top of my
head where i would say that is a number
that is bad but like you'll see some
numbers that are well above the normal
range
in conditions of acute muscle damage
um one other question that came up that
i wanted to briefly mention someone
asked what brown adipose tissue is
that's another area where i did a little
bit of research in grad school the only
reason i want to briefly address this is
because
it's kind of picking up like every
couple years this picks up where it gets
kind of popular and people start talking
about it so
brown adipose tissue
these are fat cells just like you know
subcutaneous fat that we would think of
the white adipose tissue but the thing
that's different about brown adipose
tissue is that these fat cells have a
higher rate of metabolic activity they
have greater mitochondrial density and
in certain physiological situations they
can become stimulated to increase their
energy
utilization increase uh heat production
basically so when they get stimulated
they start metabolizing more substrates
they start generating a lot of heat and
they're basically burning energy in a
very uncoupled fashion so you're burning
calories at an accelerated rate not
necessarily to to generate atp but just
to kind of burn off some heat
for the longest time it was thought that
adult humans don't have enough to care
about it was you know we always thought
it was something that rodents had and we
thought it was something that maybe well
we knew that babies had it
but as detection methods have gotten
better
we know that adult humans do have some
and it tends to cluster around the
clavicle area and down through kind of
the base of the spine it's all up in
this not all of it but most is kind of
in this kind of clavicle neck chest area
uh so i did some work where we were
imaging that with ct and mri and in
order to induce uh
the different imaging techniques you
know we had to to pick it up with the
imaging we had to induce activation of
the brown adipose tissue we did that
with cold exposure uh and it sucked it
was not
fun like so what we would do is put
these cold uh like bags that would have
water going through them and we would
put them like over the femoral artery
and like near the armpits basically
where we could get to to you know
relatively superficial areas where blood
is flowing yeah to cool people down
pretty quickly basically like the
protocol to save someone from heat
exhaustion yeah like what if they don't
have heat exhaustion yeah and that
that's why this equipment exists in the
first place we're kind of using it for
that uh and like in order to really
significantly activate this stuff you
have to get people
very very cold but not quite to the
point of shivering but for us we needed
to avoid shivering because that would
mess up our imaging but basically you
have to be cold and you can't cheat you
can't be like oh i'm going to go in a
cold room with like two sweatshirts on
and like let myself shiver because if
you're shivering and wearing sweatshirts
you're you're you're fighting off that
cold exposure with other forms of of you
know protection from it you know you've
got the clothing on you've got the
shivering to generate heat so the reason
i bring this up every like two or three
years someone says hey if you just
expose yourself to cold conditions
you're gonna burn fat like crazy you're
gonna be shredded you're gonna lose so
much fat you won't even believe it it's
gonna be hard to keep weight on and
that's just it's just not true like the
the
impact of this
brown fat induced thermogenesis that's
increasing energy expenditure
in response to cold exposure it is so
minimal
it's not going to have a huge impact on
your physique and it is not a fun way
to go about burning a few extra calories
like it's not pleasant when you're on
the verge of shivering or even past the
point of shivering so this is kind of
popular again
i don't think it's a particularly
applicable or practical strategy worth
pursuing because he almost certainly or
almost every time someone brings up
brown adipose tissue they're trying to
use it as a or they're interested in its
potential as a fat loss hack of some
type and i just i haven't seen
convincing evidence that it has utility
there so that that those were not the
grad school related questions i thought
you were going to answer oh uh i saw one
as well uh from someone asking
uh
basically like does using mouthwash
really actually mess things up if you're
using a nitrate supplement yes uh it
absolutely does um very straightforward
answer so
when you're using beet root juice or
some other form or source of dietary
nitrate you're hoping it's going to
enhance your performance
what you're trying to do is facilitate
nitric oxide production so we've got
nitrate
which needs to be converted to nitrite
which then needs to be converted to
nitric oxide in order for this all to
work
so the conversion of nitrate to nitrite
uh is fully dependent on the bacteria
that reside uh in your your oral cavity
uh and so if you use like a really
strong antibacterial mouthwash you will
wipe out those colonies of of bacteria
in your mouth and that process
uh you know converting nitrate into
nitrite which is the critical first step
it's not going to occur and so uh yeah
when i ran a study on beetroot juice i
had to really really emphasize for all
my participants
please do not use mouthwash because if
everybody uses mouthwash they won't let
me graduate i need you to i need you to
follow these instructions uh but yeah so
it's absolutely true that uh mouthwash
is gonna is gonna wipe that out and
there's actually interesting research
that people who use mouthwash regularly
their blood pressure is just a couple
points higher uh even looking at like
big population level data which is
pretty interesting
that is very cool
um
[Music]
okay so jay bell asks uh greg once told
alan thrall that strength loss during
weight loss may be due to upper body
glycogen loss is that still his theory
how long till glycogen is restored once
you go back to maintenance uh so i'll
take the last one first how long does it
take to restore glycogen
like a day or two if eaten plenty of
carbs you'll be fine um
and so to be clear that idea uh
i would say is less of a theory and more
of a very tentative hypothesis um one of
the things that people
often note
is that when they go into a caloric
deficit start losing weight
really before there's
sufficient time to lose
really any meaningful amount of muscle
[Music]
their strength starts dropping and it
seems to affect the upper body
disproportionately like it's not
uncommon to hear someone say like oh
yeah like i lost 10 pounds squat and
deadlift went fine uh i lost 30 pounds
off my bench what gives um
and so
the the reason that i think it might be
related to glycogen to some degree uh is
there's a group of researchers headed by
by someone named orton blod uh that's
done some research looking at uh the
impact of glycogen levels and
specifically glycogen localization on
muscle fiber function
finding that basically
so you have different depots of glycogen
storage within your muscle fibers and
the intra myofibrillar glycogen depot is
the one that's the most important for
muscle contractility
and once that starts dropping muscle
contractile force uh and also shortening
velocity
um
starts decreasing quite a bit
uh and so
you know if you're seeing relatively
large strength losses in the absence of
significant muscle loss
something is going on that is affecting
muscle contractility uh and there are a
few different directions you could go
with that maybe it's central in origin
like maybe you're just having a harder
time generating motor impulses from your
brain i think that's pretty unlikely um
maybe it's slightly further along as a
central mechanism like maybe you're
generating those impulses in your brain
but there's issues like transmitting
them down your spine maybe it's
peripheral so you know
maybe
motor impulses from motor nerves it's
just taking
more and more stimulation to actually
get the muscle fibers to depolarize in
the first place
again that's theoretically possible but
i don't think it's a big deal um
in the in the absence of fatigue so you
know that could that could very easily
explain maybe a decrease in strength
endurance uh as you're dieting but that
sh i i don't think that would really
explain uh drops in top end strength and
so i think it's something that's very
localized within the muscle
and in my opinion glycogen seems like
the most
the most likely explanation um
so
glycogen replenishment
is based on both nutritional factors
obviously so you know are you eating
carbohydrate uh
are you insulin sensitive to get
insulin-mediated glut4 translocation to
get some carbohydrate into the muscle
but it's also exercise mediated so when
you're using some of your muscle mass
you get what's called non-insulin
mediated glut4 translocation
which basically just you know you're
using a muscle and so you get these
little transporters to suck carbohydrate
into the muscle uh and you know you use
your legs a lot more than your arms and
so
i would love to see direct research
looking at this but i think it's very
plausible
that when you're in a sustained caloric
deficit maybe you you do experience
sustained drops in
upper body glycogen levels
to an extent that you don't experience
for your lower body which then via those
local factors could affect muscle
contractility which would explain that
decrease in top end strength uh so that
that's kind of like
the logical flow i'm working with and
again there's direct evidence for some
of that stuff specifically the impact of
intramyofibrillar glycogen on muscle
fiber contractility um
but there's like two or three steps
along that process where there's not
direct evidence
so to be clear that is my working
hypothesis for why
upper body maximal strength seems to
decrease for a lot of people even with
pretty moderate weight loss um
but but that that is a hypothesis much
more so than a theory
cool good stuff
are there any other uh particular
questions that jump out to you
uh i will say that line of research with
the the localized glycogen depletion
that
if we had uh a list of our favorite
research areas over the last 10 years
that's easily on my top four no question
what are the other three uh
still that just four copies of that
uh no i think uh
i i've been i found the localized
glycogen depletion fascinating uh i
found the
the newest research in plant-based
protein to be fascinating because it
kind of
you know
make makes a pretty strong case that
plant-based proteins can be used pretty
effectively for for strength and
hypertrophy
which a lot of people had pretty much
accepted as not being the case
one area of research that i'm still
waiting for it to make my list because
we need more work is the caffeine and
cyp182
gene that relationship because it seems
like every time a paper comes out
it's going back and forth a little bit
i'm still a little bit skeptical that it
has a huge impact
uh you know
but
time will tell
wasn't there a study that you were
considering for mass next month which
suggested that uh
i forget which letter is the bad variant
but uh people who had the the less
advantageous cyp182 variant actually
experienced decreases in strength with
caffeine usage
there was at least one circumstance in
that paper i forget the pairing of
genotype and exercise outcome but there
was an ergolytic effect present so
i i was uh i was considering that for
research briefs this month and then when
i saw a decrease in performance in one
of the groups i was just like
nope this is research briefs i do not
want to have to extend the words it
would take to explain this
maybe eric will review it next month
yeah i mean
it's tricky because there are some
bodies of literature where as they're
developing you'll see these
discrepancies that seem to appear and
when you don't have a lot of research
yet you you don't even have a chance to
really fill in those gaps it's only
after there's a bunch of research from a
bunch of different lab groups that you
can start to tease out
these specific contributing factors
where we say oh there's an effect here
because of this but a lack of effect
here because of that until you have
different studies with different
characteristics
you're really just kind of guessing you
know so so that's kind of where we're at
with that literature in my opinion
uh oh man i saw a question here that i
really want to answer and we fit the
hour mark were you thinking about
wrapping up fairly soon uh it's up to
you
i could go either way um but i do very
much want to answer this question so
kenneth yee asks what are some studies
you'd like to see conducted um
and
the
reason i wanted to to answer that is
there's one study in particular
that i've wanted to see since college
and i don't think it's like i don't know
if it's ever going to get done uh but i
think it would be very very interesting
so
as some back story
there are a couple studies
looking at uh the placebo effect and
steroids that i think are very very cool
so uh
there was one by
the the lead researcher was ariel ar iel
i believe back back in like 1974
um
where basically they they had a group of
people train i think for seven weeks uh
they tested bench press
seated shoulder press standing shoulder
press and squat i'm pretty sure so you
know very upper body uh dominant testing
um
ba rat stop spamming a single question
or we're going to block you
um
anyway so
all right you're
blocked um
so yeah uh they they were training for
seven weeks
and um
those were the exercise they tested and
so for the first seven weeks uh no one
was using
you know anything they weren't using
steroids uh and they they told the
subjects like hey uh the ones of you
that do the best have the best strength
outcomes over the seven weeks we're
gonna give you some free steroids to use
so they they kind of had a carrot there
for the first seven weeks to motivate
them to train hard and try to gain as
much strength as they could uh and they
put i think a total of on average 10
kilos across those four lifts on their
on their 1rms uh across the first seven
weeks of training and then they gave
them placebo pills for um
they gave them placebo pills for another
four weeks told them it was gear uh it
wasn't anything it was a sugar pill
and they had them trained for another
four weeks same basic program
and over four weeks they put 45 kilos on
their total of those four lifts they
were testing
so
they gained strength at like eight times
like seven eight times the rate that
they were previously um with really no
change other than they thought they were
taking gear and so you know obviously
that's just one study i would like to
see a direct replication of that
but then there was another study by
maggie norris from like 2000 2001
where they did something similar but it
was more of an acute design and they
used
internationally competitive power
lifters and this is actually one of my
favorite studies ever just because of
the human element of it
so um
it was i believe the great british uh
ipf team so these were single ply
lifters they were pretty strong i think
the average squat was like just north of
600 pounds or like somewhere somewhere
in that that general range
um yeah it's ipf it's drug tested but
these guys were just like hey look we
think other people are probably using
gear it's like we want to use some gear
as well so they go to their coach and
they say like hey uh
can you hook us up with some steroids
and the coach who was a researcher um
was basically just like ah yes now i
have an opportunity to study the placebo
effect so he betrayed their trust um
instead of getting them steroids he gave
them uh placebo pills and so the way the
study worked is tested their 1rms then
uh two weeks later they he gave them
placebo pills
and uh had them test their one rms again
and they put an average of like four or
five percent on their lifts which
increasing your total by four or five
percent if you're an internationally
competitive lifter is insane uh
and also the interesting thing about
that is it shows that these guys also
didn't know a single thing about how
steroids work like they're supposed to
make you bigger and stronger over time
but uh i i guess the coach was just like
hey take this pill today it'll make you
strong um
and so yeah they they tested way better
after taking these pills one time
and so then for the next two weeks uh
their coach kept giving them placebo
pills
and uh like just ask them
uh
like you know kind of uh qualitatively
how's your training going how are you
feeling uh and you know people were
reporting man i'm lifting loads i've
never lifted before i'm recovering way
better i see why people like steroids
steroids are awesome so like they
self-report man best two weeks of
training of my life and then uh after
that he told half of them hey these have
been placebos all along the other half
still believed they that they were using
gear
tested their 1rms again the people who
had been been told that they'd been
taking placebos the whole time
even now with the knowledge that like
hey
actually there's a great two weeks of
training that was all me i didn't need
steroids for that they still regressed
to like their pre-steroid numbers they
lost the four to five percent that the
placebo steroids had given them uh the
other the other subjects who
still thought that they were taking
steroids
they maintained their elevated
performance and some of them even
experienced further increases in
strength um
so
anyway i think both of those studies are
very interesting and again we're talking
about a really small body of literature
here uh and one of the things we see in
placebo research is like placebos
ultimately work via expectancy effects
like they don't physiologically do
anything but
uh
positive expectancy tends to make things
better and the degree of positive
expectancy elicited by a particular
placebo protocol depends on what
type of placebo it is so
you know in like pay search for example
um if you give someone a pill that can
elicit a placebo effect uh if you give
someone
a placebo injection that that's a bigger
placebo so there's more expectancy
attached to it that elicits a larger
placebo effect and then some studies
have even used like sham surgeries where
like they someone under make an incision
but don't actually do anything and that
elicits an enormous placebo effect
because you think you just had surgery
done
uh
so anyway
in the realm of like supplements and
things you could put in your body to as
an ergogenic like obviously if you're
taking placebo caffeine like you're
taking a sugar pill you think is
caffeine but isn't that's not going to
elicit as large of a as large of a
placebo effect as placebo steroids would
uh but ultimately i think those two
studies illustrate maybe like the upper
bounds of benefits that one could derive
from positive expectancy effects
and so that's a really long lead up to
the study that i would like to do
because like ultimately
you know
you can't really trick people into
thinking they're taking steroids forever
or at least like it wouldn't be
uh ethical to do
and
i was going to say it wouldn't be
economically viable but like it totally
is there
there's research where uh
like researchers buy black market
steroids and test what's in it and like
40 of it is just completely bunk uh so
anyway i guess i guess it might actually
be profitable but it certainly wouldn't
be ethical so you know thinking to
myself
how might one be able to elicit
relatively large positive expectancy
effects in a way that would be ethical
uh and so i think a cool study to do
would be
to um like have two groups of people
and one of the groups like basically
they train the way people typically
train in a study like it's just you and
some research assistants
alone in a sterile little gym well
oftentimes it's not that sterile but you
know it's it's a gym that's like it's
not super hype it's just you and the
research assistant you don't really have
anything to base your expectations on
for
like what resistance training does to a
person and you train you know maybe get
stronger maybe you build muscle uh
hopefully good things happen but then
the other group in the study they're
working out like in like a d1 football
training facility while the team is
training and so
ideally these would be untrained people
uh and so like
their first exposure to resistance
training and what one might be able to
expect from resistance training uh
is like d1 football players and so like
they're they're basically raised in that
environment and then you see what the
results look like i kind of think that
uh
i mean one of the things that a lot of
especially strength athletes note is
that one of the things that helps them
take the results to the next level is
finding a really really good gym to
train at like you know like maybe you're
gifted for strength you're training at a
gold's gym for a while you get stronger
but then like a power lifting gym opens
up in your city you go you train there
there's people there who are a lot
bigger and stronger than you
and then you realize like huh maybe i'm
not such hot [ __ ] like maybe this is
what i should be aiming for uh and then
you have like a pretty notable boost in
results pretty quickly like that's
that's a really common anecdote and and
i wonder if that is
i don't just wonder i strongly suspect
that that's related to positive
expectancy effects like not just being
able to see strong people doing stuff on
the internet but being able to see
strong people doing stuff in person
i think that i think that has a really
large positive psychological effect on
people
um
and their their ideas of like what can i
hope to accomplish what should i be
shooting for
where should i expect to plateau like oh
man i'm struggling with a 400 pound
squat like oh maybe i'm kind of strong
and like things are gonna start getting
hard now if you see the guy in the rack
next to you squatting 800
you're not even going to think about 400
like that's just so anyway i think that
would be a really really cool study to
do
um
and yeah for the last
decade that's that's the study i've
wanted to see
yeah that would be cool
all right uh one thing that we probably
should address should have addressed at
the beginning is uh
i always
so someone commented on my expression
they said it looked like i was so done
with uh with you
and with
with the audience
[Laughter]
i don't know how to explain it that's
just how i look isn't it
yeah so um
well i i know we've mentioned this on
the podcast before but now people are
finally able to see it
uh
eric has two resting faces he has uh
what he describes as resting crisis face
yeah which is
when he's thinking about anything at all
doesn't even have to be lost in thought
uh just looks like
he
he has recently heard the most tragic
news that has ever occurred someone
commented resting [ __ ] face it's not
resting [ __ ] face it's resting crisis
face because it's not just like bad news
but it's like
it's like
as if i were the president of the united
states and there's an immediate crisis
that needed my attention like yeah i
have to solve this right now and the
stakes are impossibly high yeah so
that's one of them or just like
annoyed is not the right word just like
resting checked out face
yeah so
i i have a bad memory
and uh
a lot of uh
i've wondered to what extent my
concussion history plays into that but
when i think more deeply about it i've
always had a bad memory and i think it's
because i actually
spent most of my childhood simply not
present like mentally fully checked out
yeah i wasn't actually in coding
memories because i wasn't observing
anything around me like i was completely
in a different uh
a different world but but no i've been
here the whole time but you know
sometimes i just look like i'm either
totally spaced out or dealing with a
really existential crisis but yeah that
that is completely normal uh don't be
alarmed best i can tell he's not mad at
me right now i don't think he's mad at
you guys uh
things are totally fine yeah um
so we didn't want to make this like a 90
minute sales pitch for the app but we
have gotten a lot of questions about the
app many people have been asking about
it there have been quite a few uh been
asking more and more
any of the best people yeah
one question that i did want to briefly
address was
does macro factor accommodate protein
intakes for vegan and vegetarian folks
uh and the answer is yes and i think one
of the cool features about the app is
that you can actually look at the amino
acid profile of your protein sources uh
i think that's a really really cool uh
it's cool to me because as i mentioned
on the podcast i'm on the path to
enlightenment in my secular buddhist
quest and so i haven't been eating any
meat lately and so i do like to check in
sometimes and see if i'm getting all my
essential amino acids and stuff so i
think that's a really cool part but we
are gonna have uh another
i think it's fair to say this went well
enough to replicate right
yeah so we're gonna have another live
youtube thing the night we launched the
app and so i think we should probably
save a lot of the app questions for that
event because that'll be totally on
topic yes september 16th and we're gonna
have a launch party um
we're gonna
just just exclusively be shilling the
app answering your questions maybe
drinking champagne popping bottles yeah
um
it's gonna be a blast yeah so everyone
could join the uh the release party this
time i i just got drunk before we
started recording so yeah you know
wouldn't be tacky there wouldn't be the
sound of the bottle getting sat down on
the table yeah um yeah next time you'll
you'll be able to see my mental state
devolve in real time but we we did uh
the sales page is live right it is so if
people want to take a look at some of
the features they could see that now i
believe
yeah so if you want to go to stronger by
science.com
macro factor
you can check out the sales page
i think it's pretty slick
personally
paints the app in a very good light
which isn't difficult because it's an
excellent app um
[Music]
and yeah oh this is interesting uh you
know ryan asked about some dating advice
he asked if macro factor could be a
dating app any app can be a dating app
if you try hard enough yeah that's an
interesting feature that we will look
into
um
were there any other questions that you
wanted to uh
to look at before we
sign off
um
i should say uh you know
there were obviously more questions that
we could possibly answer tonight and we
do appreciate that we really uh
appreciate everybody for joining us
especially on really short notice
um
but keep your questions we do q and a's
on the podcast all the time
usually a day or two before we're going
to record a normal podcast
in our facebook group and in our
subreddit we'll say hey anybody have any
questions so hold on to your questions
you can submit them there and hopefully
we'll be able to get to them on the show
someday and i don't know maybe we'll do
more of these live events as well who
knows i mean i enjoyed it um
i think we know
about enough things that we can field
questions live i think it makes it more
interactive and it means we don't have
to prepare which uh which is nice yeah
well we will still yeah
we will definitely uh keep that in mind
that that is a very doable thing of the
future i'm a little bit annoyed about
this one someone asked if if i could
start doing a secular buddhism segment
on the podcast it's called road to
enlightenment it's the road to
enlightenment listen to the recent
episodes lure carter i literally do it
already but outrageous i do need to make
that segment better but
i don't
so i really painted myself into a corner
with that segment because i don't
i'm in no position to be teaching about
secular buddhism yeah i'm like a novice
level entry-level beginner
uh and i also
i didn't stop sam harris
[Laughter]
close the chat before we get a bunch of
negative comments
uh
but i'm also like
a relatively private person so i can't
even like lean on like anecdotes of my
inner being and my journey through
buddhism i don't know what i don't know
what i planned for that segment but uh
it is is crashing and burning so i need
to figure out what to do
some people don't even know it exists i
mean that's on you it is
um all right any last question you want
to get to here i think i'm good all
right uh once again we really do
appreciate everyone for joining us we
absolutely are going to do this again uh
two weeks from tonight it'll be 8 p.m
eastern
uh it will be the official macro factor
launch party it's the diet app that
we've been working
for ages to put together we've been
working on that thing forever we're
stoked about it and we're excited to
share it with everybody uh beta testing
has been going really really well so we
think uh if you choose to check out the
app we do think you'll really enjoy it
based on the feedback we've gotten here
so
uh i'm going to stumble around and try
to figure out how to close a youtube
live uh and we're signing off so once
again thanks everybody